also hier unser Interview mit dem Grafen
zum Thema Bundes Bundesvision Song
Contest ist auch für dich schwierig
auszusprechen Bundesvision Song Contest
die Kurzform ist
buisco buisco ja buisco ne bisoko
Biso super macht ja auch total
intelligent und fr falsch aus also
buisoko genau also zum buvisoko unser
Interview mit dem Grafen der für NRW
antritt mit unter deiner Flagge wie
kommt man zu so einem ja zu
beim bundesvion ja man fragt ob man da
mitmachen darf ne und es war so mein
Ziel immer mal so ein bisschen so fürs
eigene Heimatland Heimat buundesland
anzutreten also es ist natürlich so dass
ich ganz aufgeregt bin weil das Lied ist
natürlich auch für meine Mama
geschrieben das habe ich für meine Mama
geschrieben und dann auch noch fürs
eigene Bundesland antreten das ist
natürlich schon cool riesen Ehre bin
auch ganz aufgeregt gibt's den schon
Wetten die anderen Wetten also bei mir
ist so ich habe die Einstellung dabei
ist alles und sehe das ein bisschen als
als olympischen Gedanken wieder ein
schweres Wort genau wie buwiisoko und
ähm also viele reden immer davon
Unheilig du bist ja eh Favorit also ich
glaube hast du eigentlich schon verloren
ne also ich glaub der wenn du als
Favorit irgendwo reingehst kannst du nur
so verlieren und ich mache das wirklich
so dass ich einfach mal erstmal abwarte
ich meine wer ruft schon an für ein
Typen der sein Lied singt für die Mama
das ist ja eigentlich total uncool und
äh aber das ist mir egal trotzdem die
Frage
wer favorisiert dich und warum
äh die anderen favorisieren mich ich
glaube das liegt daran weil momentan für
unheilich ganz viel passiert also ne wir
sind jetzt ewige Wochen auf der Nummer 1
vor sechs Monaten kannte uns keiner also
kaum kaum kaum einer und jetzt wird
überall davon gesprochen im Radio wird's
läuft's rauf und runter und aus dem
Grunde glauben wohl viele dass wir jetzt
auch auch so so gewinnen würden aber man
darf auch nicht vergessen da spielen ich
und ich mit selig und alleine diese
beiden Bands die habe ich noch vor ein
paar Jahren auf der Couch zu Hause
gesehen wo ich dachte boah war super und
jetzt bist du mit denen auf Augenhöhe
quasi und das ist hallo ich mein ich mE
ich glaube selig haben über 10 Jahre
schon erfolgreich Musik und wenn du dann
so als Newcomer kleiner der gerade erst
7 Monate aktuell ist da kommst also ich
fühle mich noch nicht so dass ich da
irgendwie auf Augen bin gut okay
trotzdem alle drücken die Daumen und vor
allen Dingen
klicksum drückt dir die Daumen weil ich
bin in Anführungszeichen dein
offizieller Youtube parte ehrlich ja
sensationell oder Hammer der Hammer oder
weil klicksum ist der am meisten
abonnierte Kanal aus Nordrheinwestfalen
haben wir rausgekriegt und wir gucken
immer aus jedem Bundesland dass wir auch
den stärksten YouTube-Kanal bekommen und
ich sage jetzt also ruft auf jeden Fall
beim bundeswischen Song Contest an für
Unheilig ja ja auf jeden Fall anrufen
anrufen anrufen so und hier auf Youtube
favorisiert dieses Video schaut es so
oft wie möglich an gibt thumbs ab
und dann hat nämlich dieses Video von
Unheilig auch die Chance hier bei
YouTube ziemlich weit nach oben zu
schnellen und damit zu zeigen Unheilig
ist tatsächlich der Favorit das wäre der
absolute Hammer ja machen gute Idee
super also alle drücken die Daumen wir
auch und was kann man jetzt noch
Wünschen für so Wettbewerb also ich
glaube man sagt immer to to to und Du
darfst da nicht danke sagen ne genau to
to